wow
schluss
hey leute ich war halt heimat schwimmen
also ich war mit dem kopf unter wasser
und die waren sofort weg das ist ich
habe mir das gestern schon gedacht habe
gestern ein mal geduscht damit und die
wand zum komisch und jetzt bin ich
einmal unter wasser tauchen gegangen die
sind einfach weg was soll das ich habe
50 euro bezahlt immer wie die sich
anfühlt wieder ganz normal ich bin
überlegt ja richtig kaputt
liebe frau die das gemacht hat
bitte macht es demnächst ordentlich das
gerät ich verstehe es überhaupt vor mir
habe auch richtig viele gesagt du warst
ja nur eine stunde normalerweise dauert
das vier sterne oder so aber die sagte
mir dass wir jetzt ein bisschen
deprimiert auf
ich weiß viele von euch wollten das
immer so dass ich die wieder back waffe
aber
ja nicht voll verarscht oder ich habe
heute nacht einfach zwei schon
geschlafen wir sind eben angekommen ich
wollte unbedingt auf einmal ins meer
und dann das egal die handtücher der
kontinente hier dabei hat doch in runde
drei rollen auf dem roller hier viel
spaß am laufen war kalt man dort kannst
du deine kamera mit und kein antiker
weil wir in filmen bildern noch warten
wir auf instagram viel spaß
naja egal wir sind hier in spanien
und es kommen jetzt wirklich fast
täglich videos wollte ich dann noch mal
anmerken wenn sich die situation schon
ergibt oder die möglichkeit und mir ist
kalt sind da gar keine trades also auch
keinen ansatz so ein bisschen aber
plötzlich wieder zu hause auf jeden fall
meine haare sind jetzt gerade so aus ich
habe überhaupt nicht gemacht aber die
sind echt lang geworden
ihr könnt ja in die kommentare schreiben
oder wenn zu viel besser gefällt dass
man daumen nach oben da dann riecht das
ja seid ihr wieder zufrieden hongkong 18
uhr auch echt ein geiles video durch die
auf keinen fall verpassen
er zeige ich euch nämlich ein bisschen
was von diesem oder ich zeige euch
eigentlich alles so was richtig oder
sieht hier ein neues zuhause und so
weiter
juli wenn sowas sagen also ich bin
viel viel besser ausgeschaltet so heftig
hier ohne witz heute durch das video
morgens für kamera und abonnieren
er beschreibt